[Musique]
ok
[Musique] la
première fois que je l'ai vu en ligne, je pensais
bien, je ne suis pas sûr que cela soit autorisé là-bas,
je veux dire, il y a deux personnes qui brisent ces
escrocs plus tôt et juste une libération conditionnelle pour tous ceux que
vous connaissez et donc la règle d'un mètre et demi
quoi  Il s'avère que c'est plus une question de
sécurité ici
[Musique]
nous apprenons maintenant comment faire le
ménage comment faire le service comment
sortir les assiettes vides de la
serre de manière élégante pour que
vous vous sentiez toujours pris  nous nous occupons vraiment
bien donc il y a encore beaucoup à
apprendre pour nous dans ces nouvelles
technologies, comme comment pouvons-nous préparer notre
petit-déjeuner lors de l'événement
[Musique]
vous